the lower lower worm is a parasite that  can cause severe joint pain and even  death in central Africa the worm also  creates a problem for health officials  who are trying to prevent infections  with other parasites that's because a  low a low infection can cause severe  reactions to the drugs used to prevent  those other parasites this new tool  called the CellScope Lowa can avoid that  problem it's made using 3d printed parts  and uses the camera on a regular iPhone  turning it into a video microscope in  less than 2 minutes it can identify  someone carrying low Aloha all it needs  is a drop of blood a finger prick will  do then it takes video of the blood and  software locates the invisible worms  looking for their unique wriggling  pattern as they push red blood cells  around this offers a potentially cheap  and easy way to test patients on the  spot and prevent giving them treatments  that could have serious consequences  you